charge and he's got a really wide
opening repertoire actually for someone
so young usually when you're younger you
specialize in one area and then you
slowly add new openings but Arjun can
play anything okay it's the Italian game
um so this one could get very
complicated later could get very tense
but uh we could also see a very kind of
slow maneuvering battle this one is rich
and full of possibilities
one thing I was going to say Arjun he
will find a way to mix things up he will
find a way to be aggressive and kind of
complicate things maybe go for the world
champion at some points that's
definitely something he's capable of
just right now after that first game
it's important that he just recovers
forgets and okay this last bishop move
we saw him employ a Magnus frowning
that's a bit strange we saw uh Arjun
employ something very similar to this
yesterday against Liam Lee
and it worked out quite well Magnus
however has come prepared and this
bishop move
I've never seen it before database also
confirms another novelty yeah
what could the idea be as bizarre this
bishop move it looks like a really
passive Square gets in the way of the
black queen
I'm struggling to explain it to be
honest I guess the only idea is that
Magnus doesn't want to commit his King
yet the black king if it had castled on
this right side of the board might have
been weak we saw that yesterday Arjun
won a very very nice game against Liam
when the black king on the king side got
attacked so maybe Magnus just staying
flexible he's trying to surprise his
young opponent
yeah I I agree and I have to say it this
move although it's never been seen
before it does have the approval of the
computer so I am also keeping an eye on
the engine this that follows um Magnus
Carlsen sassy sassy says we're only tiny
smidgen better for white
zero doubt that this has been cut
scars and his coaches maybe Peter heiner
Nielsen uh somewhere in a lab just with
the strongest engine strongest computers
so we're not going to criticize that
move he just looks odd from a human
point of view
um yeah the black Bishop normally it
develops to maybe challenge the white
light Square Bishop normally a challenge
comes out to maybe create a pin on white
tonight but
just maybe a waiting move clever waiting
move yeah and I I do wonder whether that
Bishop has maybe got some designs of
potentially supporting uh the advance of
the apron
[Music]
I'm like grasping at straws here David
so we should explain that usually in
this position black has two ways of
dealing with this pin either you just
leave it forever or at some point you
push this pawn and if you push this Pawn
white will Retreat the black king now
it's a bit stuck if it stays in the
center it will come under Fire the
center will explode at some point when
white pushes forward and of course if it
castles on this side of the board for
example now then the king very open for
a week and uh instead Magnus he's saying
okay I'm gonna just leave this pin for
now it's not dangerous at the moment
bringing this bishop out as we mentioned
usually the the black Bishop comes to
this Square potentially this square and
uh instead after developing as you
mentioned Ivanka maybe if White's Knight
brings itself out for example Magnus
will continue to wait maybe Magnus can
come and try and hunt down White's light
squared Bishop
I mean I'm struggling to find reasons
why this is a good move but I guess he's
moved a piece out into the position if
Magna if Arjun just Waits I think this
might be a good way to ask Magnus what
his idea is what is your strategy yeah I
mean I like the idea of waiting I think
that's a great I am suggestion and uh
what about this idea of moving the work
well there potentially the idea of just
pushing forward in the center saying hey
you've taken a move we all like Square
Bishop instead of getting your king to
safety Let's uh mix things up
uh I like it White's Rook normally
belongs on this Square anyway staring
down potentially at the black king
and uh I wouldn't be surprised if Magnus
Retreats this bishop this bishop is
about to get hit so why not step it back
and this is what Magnus likes to do in
general he likes to preempt any opening
of the center by dropping his Bishop
back he did this in the world
championship match in 2021 last year
still don't really see what this black
Bishop is doing but the computer doesn't
hate it nowadays computers just opened
our eyes to all sorts of possibilities
that look so unnatural and maybe the
reason he's keeping his King in the
center is that he might want to go for
this Pawn push and an attack just
without putting his King on that flank
so I think it's just about flexibility
like you showed in the last game he kind
of stayed and waited and waited and then
eventually a plan became clear and he
went for it against sergeant and maybe
he's doing the same again yeah so you
accept respect him not to Castle
at least the the fact that he's stopped
now for more than one minute and he
hasn't castled immediately
makes me think that he's going to delay
it as long as possible probably
commentators Castle now but uh I think
that's maybe the only way to justify
this last Bishop moved by black and
there we go he does retreat he's going
to wait he's going to see what happens
first and then that pawn push the black
Jeep won't come into attack where it's
Bishop on the edge of the board he might
go for that if the moment is right yeah
do do you think that Magnus has uh well
I really hesitate to even suggest this
ideas of maybe even going with his King
to the queen side
seen him do that a few times we have and
uh I don't know I suspect that he's
biding his time and just when Arjun
least expects it that King
switches attack yeah and I mean I'm
trying to recall this tournament he won
Magnus by casting Queen side as black
against Iranian he won by casting Queen
side as white against Vincent Kyler I
think he won one in the prelims as well
was it against Sergeant it was against
someone
uh so Magnus he's
he's definitely trying to throw his
opponents off with kind of weird ideas
unseen ideas and this is the difference
maybe between the very elite uh the
Carlsons of the world and maybe
um slightly less kind of elite players
just they have teams around them who do
their homework who study who come up
with new ideas creative ideas and for
the rest of us it's just hard to keep up
it is definitely hard to keep up and uh
while talking about Keith get keeping up
we have Magnus Carlson he's just used 15
seconds of his time paragisi well he's
down to 12 minutes so still a lot of
time but it's very clear that Arden
doesn't quite know what plan he should
adopt and he's gone for a flexible
approach just developing the night and
now this is the moment I want to see
what is magnus's big idea is he gonna
attack the bishop and is he going to
Castle kingside is he gonna
keep waiting keep waiting I um he might
he might do that yeah it's like that big
reveal and uh it's not the only big
reveal we're waiting from uh waiting for
from Magnus so they're both kind of
waiting for the other player to take the
first initiative the other player to
show their plan first yeah essentially
so the left side of the board is pretty
locked down neither side's really going
to play there at least white won't play
on this left side of the board the
center there's a chance for both sides
to step forward more likely that white
will step forward and on this King side
on the right half of the board it's more
likely that black is going to make the
move there so for example if black plays
on the right side of the board white
wolf kind of fight in the center and
force things open and especially while
the black King's there it's not safe so
Magnus may be waiting in that regard
um if white pushes in the center without
being provoked then maybe he weakens
himself in the process and black will
happily castle and then he'll say okay
you've committed
it's just a it's a weird type of waiting
game it just feels like they're both
tiptoeing around each other and I am
slightly surprised that Magnus is
thinking now because as you said Ivanka
this is like the most natural plan for
whites the most common type of idea why
moving his Knight across maybe the White
Knight will kind of sit next to the
white king later
um surely now he will reveal his
intentions
yeah
and whilst we're waiting for the big
mystery to be solved well we have a few
pictures from our viewers and the first
one is from
um it's written in Russian do any of you
know how to read Cyrillic uh
now I also don't know so I'm sorry I so
I'm gonna also known as the Black Widow
and uh she says gm1 and gm2 in the
making oh Beware of the future Grand
Masters and she's doing some good
training there because she's there
they're there with the iPad listening to
David's commentary getting that
subliminal messaging through ah I agree
that is the way forward
yeah yeah looks like twins as well yes
definitely
all right well they will have a fierce
fight growing up who will become
Grandmaster first oh yeah there aren't
too many twins that are Grand Masters I
think that's that's true yeah actually
because you guys were talking about
twins yesterday and I started thinking
about that because in other sports you
see a lot of twins yeah
but uh Brian Brothers in tennis yeah and
Campbell which is a big sport to know
where there's plenty of twins okay
you know I don't know any at least I
mean Simon mentioned yesterday that uh
from England there's a couple of twins
one is a grand master one's an
international master and there's uh
maybe a couple of cases I know like that
but I can't name it where they're both
Grand Masters no I I can't either
strange unless the vovok brothers are
twins but I don't think they are no
there's fears between them
the mistress Master of the Silas
Brothers there's a few years between
them
maybe it's because it gets uh maybe it's
because it gets too competitive they
just they get tired of it true maybe
those uh that we saw today in that
picture imagine in I don't know 12 years
time they'll both be grand Masters and
we'll look back at this point 12 12 yeah
12.10 yeah
we've been too conservative there
wants to give them time to enjoy their
childhood yeah
yeah and well start s even like Magnus
is in
in thinking so I have another chance to
share with you another picture this time
from Marco Francis who says I have a
question on a picture but I have a
question for everyone in the studio Kai
Ivanka and David what do you choose a
pair of nights or a pair of Kinder
buenos oh I'll do the chocolates
I don't like the knights I want the
Bishops I'll choose the Kinder as well
the ninth the night the night
and I'll try it I'll play you both over
the chessboard yeah two nights alone
Checkmate there we have the picture in
kindergart that's one of my favorite
chocolates as well I love it yeah the
problem is that you can eat too many of
them oh yeah and it feels like you've
eaten nothing at all and uh here we have
the big plan has been revealed David
yeah and I've got mixed feelings to be
honest uh firstly the fact that Magna
spent so much time on this plan when
I mean if he's done his preparation if
he's played such an odd bishop move a
novelty again then that should be a
clear follow-up and also it's very very
weakening and it looks a bit slow to
retreat to this night on the last move
but you're more optimistic Ivanka you
love pushing those Pawns
I pause but you know I'm not really a
big risk taker so I like to do it when I
have control of the center and here it
feels like the center could be blasted
open at any point of the game and I just
feel this is playing with fire here it
really is and uh magnus's plan if given
time if Arjun doesn't push the spawn
forward in the center right now uh so he
gains some space on the other on the
other side of the board magnus's idea is
to just plant his two knights on this
side they're great Defenders but also
potentially great attackers and suddenly
these two black pawns might start
running forward and they have clear
targets these two pieces are misplaced
they're easily hit by these black pawns
and Arjun might well get one of these
pieces trapped if he's not careful so I
don't think he should give time to Black
uh to just park his Knights on the side
of the board I think it feels like now
is the moment you're the one who taught
me event of the phrase you go backwards
and black has just gone backwards I go
forwards and
the most natural move in the position by
a mile is to step forward with the pawn
yeah that is very natural yeah the
stronghold in the center is attacked
three times I don't think black really
wants to capture firstly white can
establish a nice Pawn Duo but also white
could consider stepping forward and
suddenly look at the white Rook look at
the black king the central line is
opening and Black's King will regret not
having castled
I'm struggling to understand the idea to
be honest if white does step forward in
the center maybe arjun's also
considering a movement such as this one
bring the queen out the queen of Bishop
together hit this Pawn also the queen
hits this Pawn so it's kind of a double
attack but it feels a bit wrong to bring
the White Queen so far away from the
action the action will happen in the
center and on the king side where
White's King sits yeah I I agree um
don't touch the queen I think this is a
bit of a no-go area sometimes in chess
you just got to use logic right yeah I
mean this is the most logical move you
don't want to play Slowly The Apprentice
retreated
it makes complete sense to me you know
put pressure on the pawn and uh I I
suspect that Magnus is maybe gonna
Gambit the pawn okay and here it comes
find out because at this point is
attacked three times remember we don't
want to touch it and Magnus you're right
he does get a bit of Pawn on what is the
idea here white if he captures this way
I guess black can just take back
this is already a bit scary but black
can recapture and if we see another
capture by white another exchange white
is one upon but at the very end black
can play Bishop takes Pawn check
throwing in a double attack if White's
King steps out into the open and takes
then there will be a night Fork hitting
the king and hitting the bishop and uh
after this we count the pieces after the
smoke is cleared and we see his level
material still hard to evaluate to be
honest but black at least has a very
strong Knight on an outpost in the
center
so uh we will find out perhaps how to
evaluate this position
Arjun has taken in the center and I'm
expecting Magnus to recapture correct
tweet by Peter heiner Magnus Carlson's
coach seven minutes ago one gets the
impression that our guys he has not
studied the games from the 2018 under 14
girls Brazilian Championship is Magnus
playing something from that well quite
possibly ah maybe this novelty a few
moves ago here
um bringing this bishop forward maybe it
had been played in that tournament all
those years ago hmm yeah
who knows um maybe you never know with
these things maybe it's happened before
but not according to my database but uh
but I don't know if under 14 Brazilian
Championship would be in databases
well if haino is quoting it then it's
probably in the mainstream databases
perhaps not on the online database but
well
who came up with this devastating ideas
you know sometimes research sorry
Novelties and good ideas they happen
from anyone actually it just takes some
people just to sit there and think maybe
there's there's a coach at play maybe
it's just your moment of Genius Like A
young players tend to have that creative
spark when you're young you have your
mind is like a clean slate um you just
you look at the position you come up
with ideas when you're a bit older at
least myself I find I just fall into the
same patterns and the same ideas so it's
harder to come up with new ideas
um yeah maybe Mark just taking
inspiration from the kids from the
youngsters that would be kind of cool we
will ask him about that later now and
the bar has gone over to his side yeah
it has and I think he might be getting
ready to do what Ivanka mentioned
castling on the queen side it looks a
bit open for black on that flank black
has pushed his ape on but
if it gains time if you can go for the
white king later
it's going to spice things up for us at
least
it's it's going to be a lot of fun for
us because the margin for errors
suddenly decreases and uh well yeah they
have to play very accurately and both
sides are going to be attacking the
other and I'm particularly worried for
Arjun actually because it feels like
Black's attack is a lot more menacing
and maybe easier to play however having
said that I really like his last move
developing the night and that night is
getting ready to spring forward and look
at that on the board the King has gone
to the left yeah castling on opposite
flanks is always fun to watch it always
leads to Crazy complications a race
quite often whose attack is fastest like
you said Ivanka Black's attack is
already made that just pushes pawns
towards the white king Black's Knights
are sitting there ready as well to join
in
no pieces around the black king the
white piece has taken age to create a
threats even and yeah I like it as well
for black it's just the trend of the
tournament Magnus kind of delaying
castling for as long as possible and
then often just when the opponent least
expects it he runs and uh yeah that I
want to clarify that tweet from Peter
Heine maybe we need someone to tweet him
back and ask but I did want to walk in
on Magnus and he was looking at I think
it was the Pan American Under 12
championship and he was just playing
through a game I mean he just loves
watching chess he's always just on chest
24 looking at the live games and
wow and finding inspiration from kids as
well sometimes yeah
it's crazy I'll follow the top
tournaments but he follows everything so
wait one second so Magnus Charles is
Magnus Carlson that is he was still that
he was the world champion and you caught
him I mean watching I phrased it weirdly
like I caught him doing something
okay he was just scrolling through live
games and I asked him what it was and he
was like I don't know it's like some
Pan-American under like junior
Championship
oh my God that's insane that the world
champion is not like too big to look at
any old tournament I love that I think
that's just incredible it just goes to
show how passionate he is about the game
and uh probably why he is so dominant
yeah no one watches more chess than him
maybe exactly I must confess I am not
looking at the games of the undertone
and American sometimes
yeah it's just that hunger for knowledge
it's the Curious mind and uh meanwhile
this game is turning in Black's favor
look at the evaluation bar White's last
queen move we actually saw this in the
first game where Magnus also as white
put his Queen on the Square but there
there's a clear purpose here what is the
purpose behind this queen move
looks frankly bizarre to me
um the White Queen is not on a kind of
open Line she's not on an active Square
she's defending anything controlling
anything the only reason I Can See For
That Queen going to that square is that
Arjun is worried about the H Pawn moving
up the board and so therefore he's uh
preempting that pawn Push by preparing
perhaps the Knight takes porn as a or
maybe the night springing forward yeah
maybe the idea is the night's bringing
forward hitting the black queen and
after for example an exchange at least
now when black deals with the problem of
his Knight maybe there's an idea of
taking the spawn with his Queen
but again this I use the word if there
two or three times in that sentence and
that's very relevant because it's a big
if Magnus doesn't necessarily need to
push this Pawn uh for example I would be
tempted to throw the knight in I'd be
tempted to maybe move this Knight as
well over either to take this bishop or
to get into the position
Foursquare is often quite juicy for
black
I mean also
we should point out at this point I
don't think can be captured right now it
looks like it's margins just set a small
trap black can go upon up but white will
create a discovered attack move the
Knight out the way hitting the black
queen also suddenly hitting the Black
Knight this would end in disaster so I
mean the first thing that came to my
mind as soon as Arjun played it was like
was it a mouth slip is he just trying to
set a kind of a
pretty basic trap
I don't think Magnus will fall into that
one no but yeah maybe like you said it's
just aimed against black pushing the
pawn and trying to trap this white
Bishop maybe he could still consider it
to be honest but
um okay Magnus just takes her time out
brings this Rook across over defending
his Central Pawn
a bit odd I thought the blackbrook might
start pushing kind of support upon push
later but
yeah still very tense yeah and I have to
say I really liked your night with
sortie where I came to the edge of the
board and found itself on the beautiful
F4 square but that's still very much a
possibility and Magnus instead going for
overprotecting his pawns and the Santa
but uh okay well
this is also a lot of fun when one side
just uh just lights the match and uh
lets the spark take over
I was trying to start a fire against
that black king and I I was about to say
I don't think Magnus is going to grab a
pawn he could at least here have
captured uh twice this would have been
very tempting to some players maybe and
gone on a journey with his Queen but
okay first of all the queen would have
lost protection of this Pawn but even if
this Pawn wasn't up for grabs lines
would open up towards the black king
suddenly the black king
not feeling comfortable at all Magnus
therefore just blocks things up and
pushes the pawn now it's going to take
quite a long long time to create any
open lines towards this piece I'm
expecting Arjun at some point I just
don't know when to jump forward with
this Knight either this way or this way
because the White Knight kind of it's
just blocking things up at the moment
you need to do something active
before black does eventually start
pushing these Pawns
mm-hmm
yeah it's just really complicated who
knows I mean the evaluation bar can't
decide who's better it's not a draw it
definitely feels like someone's going to
attack and uh it'll be about who is
quicker who's more Dynamic with their
plans all right we are waiting for an
attack what a game Let's uh take a trip
to the good night what do you think
Simon is Magnus winning another one or
can Arjun win this game
well it looks very exciting at the
moment and we've got lots of people
watching the game live here and I think
we should go and say hello to the people
at the watch party having a look
obviously Arjun now is in a critical
situation he needs to bounce back from
that first game and um one thing I was
chatting to people about is how chess is
considered pretty cool in Norway I mean
everyone knows Magnus Carlson so I
wanted to just get a couple of people's
opinion on Magnus Carlson so we'll come
over here and um hi there how you doing
can you can you introduce yourself
please oh my name is Cena
and do you know Magnus Carson do you
think he's a cool character
I'm sorry but I don't because it gets
too mad when he loses but my friend on
the other hand she thinks he's very
handsome
and did have a huge crush I mean
and I have to say you do look awesome
you look you look like a proper Viking
kind of person but
any working clothes because nothing I'm
wearing today is actually liking but
sometimes I do wear um a purse that is a
copy from a viking grave in Sweden
brilliant okay I'm actually wearing
um this uh
um little purse made by a friend of mine
called them in Norwegian you say um
she had my swirl a small Workshop that
is awesome and I have to say there's a
lot of stuff going on here a lot of
interesting things we've got various
people you know having their opinions on
Magnus and I'm sure there's a lot of
Magnus fans here as well as we know
already and watching the match here live
which is great
um it's a very close match at the moment
uh right in the balance not gonna win
this one obviously if Magnus wins this
one then Arjun is under a lot of
pressure but thank you very much to our
special guest as well who does look
fantastic back to the studio how cool
the Vikings in the good night to cheer
for Magnus Carlsen even if she wasn't
his uh biggest fan very cool seeing that
they're with a little bit of a Viking
outfit we're a big fan of that Magnus
Carlsen well he will be angry uh if he
loses this game the bar has gone down to
the middle what's happening yeah simply
arjun's playing some great moves the
White Knight did jump in we love that
five square we've talked about it before
it didn't get captured White's night
sits there nice and pretty Instead The
Black Queen retreated and Arjun now has
placed a White Queen on a good Square
Magnus there frowning before Crossing
his arms that body language tells me
he's confused as well it's hard to
evaluate this position both sides look
at those four Knights as well Stack Down
four of them and it's like dominoes
somehow and uh just like Domino's things
could fall for one side uh if they're
just tipped over the edge and right now
bring the Rook across Magnus looks
surprised
do you think he's going to start trying
to attack I'm always going to trade yeah
white tonight was just too strong right
and what is the follow-up I guess this
bishop will be captured
yeah it has to be otherwise although the
pause in our guy says um thinking means
that he's considering perhaps playing
yeah there's quite nice pattern before
isn't it worse although
haven't seen that before actually I must
say um but carry on Ivanka after the
exchange yeah maybe he's considering
Rook takes Rick okay and it could also
be because yeah because he's not
replying instantly he hasn't got Pawn
takes Bishop as a pre-move so it's
either that or he's even thinking about
Bishop takes Knight but I
yeah I mean he could be thinking Arjun
in this position uh actually in the if
we go back to the current position on
the board about Rook takes Rook I was
about to say he could possibly be
thinking about Queen takes Pawn as well
and he's done it on going on the counter
attack trying to hit this bishop
counter-attacking
black is peace out right now but both
black bishops are Under Fire this piece
and this piece how do you save them both
maybe you can't
wow do you think Magda spotted that it's
hard to see actually it wasn't on my
radar so I have to be honest I was just
thinking of the action in the middle of
the board and uh you're right nothing to
be done I mean if you're going to play
it safe you slide the king across to
protect the bishop
if you want to I mean can you get greedy
I don't see a way yeah I don't see a way
either it feels like this bishop is the
key you can't let it drop uh I mean if
you ever move it then the White Queen is
just it's got to weigh in it's got an
entry path towards the black king so it
feels like in this position Magnus has
the Dilemma to step across with your
King again just like every Glacier on
the last move you could maybe take the
Rooks off first but uh okay he does this
and then now surely he has to stuff his
King across uh you have to keep this
bishop you can't let the White Queen in
towards your king still quite a solid
setup actually these two pieces defend
pretty well okay he does this and now
white regains the piece so white has
actually won a pawn in the process by
using his Queen and grabbing this Pawn
Magnus he's trying to compensate for
that by going forward
this game is surely he's going to end
with a winner I just don't know who but
uh it just looks like chaos the Knight
is attacked now when the Knight moves is
Black's idea to stop trying to push this
Pawn trying to blow open the position
maybe he has the idea of
going back to the original Oh plan which
I thought was initiate the attack on the
right but I don't think he has time
because the White Knight is threatening
to go over to the B5 square and here we
have it the pawn has pushed forward yeah
now it's not so easy for white to gain
time and uh to go after Black's Bishop
there's actually a threat of Checkmate
in two moves if white can take this
bishop firstly the bishop can move but
also now white has to worry about his
own King the pawn is coming down so
surely in this position this Pawn is
just too dangerous it's two squares away
from promotion get rid of it take it off
the board and he does so
yeah I mean it's so hard to call it's
just total chaos on the board yeah
absolute chaos I think he has to take
the pawn right yeah Rick you can't go
backwards in this type of position
the momentum has to keep on being kind
of propelled forward you can't you can't
lose it yeah it looks a bit dangerous
for black the king is on the back rank
it could get checkmated at some point if
a white Rook uh ever lands on this rank
but at the moment the black queen keeps
hiking just about defended
the white king as well vulnerable on
this diagonal Anything Could Happen
white is a pawn up and has the double uh
has had has the bishop pair so white is
a favorite uh art and just defends by
sliding his Bishop out very very logical
move if this Rook moves now it's going
to be ending Checkmate if the Rook
Retreats anywhere then this is going to
be a knight check discovered attack as
well uh hitting the king and when the
Knight is captured Queen takes Bishop
because this piece has been opened up
defending the queen and the king is
trapped end of the game Magnus can't
move his Rook hit in the current
position otherwise he would lose to
defend it he needs to defend his Rook so
that means a knight it just has to hop
in to the G4 Square yeah maybe this one
uh this also looks very tempting the
computers liking this one but also says
you can defend this Rook with your queen
uh so for example giving the best move
for Black by quite significantly
actually just defending with the queen
so now if the Rook is captured something
black is the one attacking
scary how is the evaluation bar so far
in the middle here I mean it's just so
unbalanced okay he does play this move
defending his Rook
entertaining us now the first game was
kind of strategic this one is just
I mean it's like dynamite this game
absolutely I mean it's what we want to
see and it's what we expected actually
from the first game we thought that you
know it would be a real slug fest with
both players just going at each other's
throats and we've been rewarded with
that right now and uh whilst Eric icy is
pausing for thought it is a complicated
position we have an interesting question
from Winston Churchill who says
and the world I'll wear that in chess
games overall white has a percentage
advantage over black in meltwater and
candidates tournaments how does this
stat correlate does white win more often
or the same or less in your opinions and
what we can pull up the stats of the
Melt water and I can see that there's a
54 score for white it's like 326 6 wins
252 losses and 355 draws which kind of
is unnervingly accurate to how it is in
classical play yeah I think at all
levels it tends to kind of uh Zone in on
that amount uh 54 for whites oh do we
have a blunder sorry yeah yeah we
absolutely do he's he's playing with
fire every guy see whether it's good or
not the evaluation bar tells us black is
winning but
how can you let the black queen so near
the white king look at the black queen
of night they're the ideal attacking Duo
the Knight is the only piece that can
move the way the queen can't and
I don't see The Knockout blow yet I must
confess but it looks scary we need to
pull up the board David because this
position is crazy because at first sight
it looks like there's going to be a
killer blow there's only one move
otherwise white is completely winning
black has one move to give himself the
advantage everything else white is going
to win uh so in this position we saw in
a capture a trade and the white king
stepping across and the computer says
black has to move a knight into the
center it says Knight D5 firstly there's
two knights that can go there I'm not
sure which one is best firstly this this
came to mind but uh suddenly I don't
know what to do if the white Rook steps
across because uh remember if the queen
moves there's going to be a Checkmate on
the back rank
maybe it has to be the other night I
think it has to be the other night and I
think the idea is if you Retreat the
night this is so difficult to see by the
way once you capture that night with
your Bishop just just say then the
Knight can actually spring forward to
the G4 square and now there is no
immediate killer blow for white because
if we go back sorry this is getting
really complicated but it is a crazy
position because if black were from the
original position were to jump in with
the Knight to G4 that would be a big Big
Blooper it would just be losing on the
spot because White Knight would jump to
C6 and after Pawn takes Knight The Rook
comes up to the eighth row and once the
king steps forward the queen will
deliver a Checkmate on A6 yeah so
actually one side is getting checkmated
if Magnus finds this move which is I've
got to say incredibly hard to see
finds it wow if he finds this move he's
doing the check mating if he found if he
played any other move he would have been
checkmated
wow uh you're Vancouver right this
Knight is coming in now there's also the
idea of some checks there's also the
Black Knight coming to take this Pawn
maybe white can't defend and again we
see the top computer moves stop fish
suggest suggesting white Bishop dropping
back that is incredibly hard any other
move
black wins on the spot essentially and
uh the first move that came to my mind
was The Rook shuffling across this is
the second best move for stockfish uh
according to stockfish hitting the black
queen the black queen can move though
with a check and uh when the white king
Runs Out The Way which I think it has to
do I think black can keep it simple now
there's still a threat of Checkmate on
the back rank but black can create some
Escape squares taking a night with Czech
and another check and yeah black would
win here because you can simply take the
bishop on the next turn instead Arjun
has gone to capture the this Knight and
Magnus he's gonna deliver Checkmate it's
Unstoppable now Checkmate coming on this
square or Checkmate coming via the
Knight on the Square two threats and the
white king is doomed
um yeah all right guys he shakes his
head he can see that he's losing game
number two as well is this due to some
inaccuracies by him or his Magnus again
playing
incredible chess I mean we can't fault
Eric I see yes he blundered but it's
from a human point of view magnus's move
was just genius right yeah and to have
calculated that and there was such a
narrow path as well he forced Magnus to
find like three or four only moves to
win anything else every Glacier would
have been winning so he kind of gambled
Eric I see and didn't pay off but
and was it that night move by Magnus
there and here we go wow Magnus Carlsen
is up by two points now in the final
everybody with the white pieces he loses
and 30 moves minus Crossing s on 5